ya estamos al final de esta audiencia
que ha durado poco más de tres semanas y
todavía hay algunas semanas más para que
la defensa de julian assange presente su
argumento final no se tomará la decisión
sobre su extradición ni el día de hoy ni
el día de mañana sino que podrían pasar
algunos meses antes del veredicto final
y hay
una reunión aquí desde temprana hora se
han dado cita a manifestantes
simpatizantes de la causa de assange
están pidiendo su liberación inmediata y
sobre todo que no sea extraditado a los
estados unidos habido un gran drama
durante estas tres semanas adentro de la
fuerte donde muchos periodistas han
podido entrar y los testimonios de la
defensa a su oración arrepentí moneo
para defender a la nasa y evitar esta
extradición